congresswoman ilhan omar's comments
comparing america and israel to
terrorist groups were so bad even her
own democratic colleagues gave her a
rare rebuke
but will there be other consequences
yeah no don't count on
should any it action be taken against
representative omar for her comments
no no i don't yeah
no i don't i think that she clarified
her
remarks and that was uh we
accepted that and she she
she has a point that she wanted to make
and she has a right to make that point
there for some an ease about how it was
interpreted
she made her clarification wow yeah
maybe nancy's backing down because she's
afraid of being called a racist
here's a tweet from rashida flaibe
freedom of speech doesn't exist for
muslim women in congress
the benefit of doubt doesn't exist for
muslim women in congress
house democrat leadership should be
ashamed of its relentless exclusive tone
policing of congresswomen of color
yes there you go classic deflection
right there joining me now is someone
who has real experience in combating
actual terrorists on behalf of the
united states rick grinnell
former acting director of national
intelligence rick thank you for joining
me tonight now
uh this is we've seen this before we've
heard horrible comments
uh from uh uh congresswoman omar and
others uh are you surprised that they're
still
handling them with such kid gloves
it's really unbelievable i mean look
they just called nancy pelosi in the
in the democratic leadership sexist
and islamophobic i i don't know how you
get around that i mean this is
this should be a top story in all of the
newsrooms of washington
this is unbelievable when somebody
imagine if a republican
called mitch mcconnell or
kevin mccarthy these names this would be
uh on everybody's front page
and and we would be talking about it
everywhere but
instead this just gets dismissed nancy
pelosi says well she's apologized
i have a question for nancy pelosi if
she apologized then
why did house leadership issue the
statement if everything was fine
why did you publicly have to do
something the answer
is because the public is outraged by
these tactics i mean
when are we going to ask right uh elian
omar and the squad about
uh gay rights in uh palestinian
territories or
what about climate change how are they
doing with climate change
in the palestinian territories and this
is this is ridiculous
yeah and here's what's fascinating is
that you've got this dynamic here maybe
it's internal polls they're looking at
is that american people really don't you
know we might not be marching in the
streets
but we are can be very quiet and then we
make ourselves known in
in the voting booth i think clearly they
must be seeing something because they
also trotted out barack obama
and that's one of their tells is that if
you need the former president
to sit down and you know talk and say
well you know cancel culture might be
going too far
is that there's some attempt to rein in
what's going on
uh and yet they seem to be unable to do
it and there's i want you to hear this
from uh pbs host yamiche alcindor
on uh now we got the g7 going on
president biden uh is uh uh there you
know
working with the some uh the other of
the people of the g7
uh and uh so she's talking here about
the u.s reputation listen to this
deep scars are are really something that
takes i've been told by experts
years and there are a lot of european
leaders who are going to be looking at
america for a long time wondering
what exactly is going on with that
democracy and it might take several
election cycles i'm being told
to really do the some of the work of
restoring trust in america
restoring trust in america you know it
seems sometimes that the socialist world
and the the unfair world does like it
better when we're in trouble
and so they did they weren't happy with
us with president trump because there
was strength
you issued strength and you know
expectations
uh what do you believe that that there
is a an effort to
get our reputation back and doesn't that
mean becoming weaker
i love her i've been told and the expert
said
right i mean these are the globalists in
the newsroom that's next to her is what
uh she is who she's hearing from the
reality is this
we have a lot of support in europe and
specifically in germany
for a strong america but but let's just
take this to
a grassroots level there are many in
germany and many in europe who don't
want a strong america because they don't
want to be told what to do
i recently had somebody tweet at me from
germany from the
think tank world in berlin saying
okay now that grinnell is gone can we go
back to those good old days where a
career diplomat
came in and said the exact same thing
but in a nicer way so that we can just
ignore them right and this is exactly
what
we're dealing with is that many people
don't like to be told what to do the
germans certainly don't want to be told
to shut down the nordstream 2 pipeline
the germans don't want to be told
to pay their fair share even though both
of those
positions are the united states policy
they've been the united states policy
for multiple administrations
we in the trump administration actually
just made a lot more progress
than others uh we can do it in a nice
way timmy
you know me i'm i'm a nice you're a nice
guy you're a nice guy you have
expectations i would never be rude
over there but i also have to remember
that i work for the american people
and i'm pushing american taxpayers
agenda there we go and
thank you rick i mean so much still
unfolding it's great to have your
expertise
and your inside appreciate you coming on
now coming up what happened
at the wuhan lab hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else